donald trump jr and many other  right-wingers immediately after the fbi  raid of donald trump's house started  saying this is radical left democrats  this is the white house this is biden  there is no evidence of that whatsoever  the white house put out a statement  saying that biden wasn't even informed  that the raid of trump's mar-a-lago was  going to be happening  in advance of it happening importantly  if we care about facts we have no facts  whatsoever that point to the white house  orchestrating anything and the fbi  director  is a guy that appoint was appointed by  donald trump christopher wray and about  whom donald trump said only stellar  positive things give it a rest guys  there's no evidence